Speaker 1: So I want to pick up our conversation
about Tulsi Gabbard that we started yesterday,
but really, this is now becoming a much bigger
story, and one of the things I'm going to show
you in a bit is the Ukrainian biolabs people
that now are fixated on the Ukrainian biolabs
story that's being promulgated by, you
know, Tucker Carlson, Glenn Greenwald,
Tulsi Gabbard, the usual suspects. These are
folks who have sort of their shiny new object
instead of covert anti-vax has shifted to become
Ukrainian biolabs. It's the same people. They're
just now paying attention to something else,
so something really funny has happened. Tulsi
Gabbard is now suggesting that Senator Mitt Romney
resign, and the idea there is that anybody cares
what Tulsi Gabbard thinks about who should
resign. That that's that's hilarious. And
all of this is centered around Tulsi Gabbard
repeating known long time Russian propaganda
talking points about Ukrainian bio. So just as
a reminder, here's the clip that started it all.
Speaker 3: Here are the undeniable facts. There
are 25 to 30 U.S. funded bio labs in Ukraine,
according to the U.S. government. These bio labs
are conducting research on dangerous pathogens.
Ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing, artillery and shelling, and
these facilities. Even in the best of
circumstances, could easily be compromised
and release these deadly pathogens like
COVID. These pathogens know no borders.
If they are inadvertently or purposely breached
or compromised, they will quickly spread all
throughout Europe, the United States and the rest
of the world, causing untold suffering and death.
So in order to protect the American people, the
people of Europe, the people around the world,
these labs need to be shut down immediately, and
the pathogens that they hold need to be destroyed
instead of trying to cover this up. The
Biden-Harris administration needs to work with
Russia, Ukraine, Naito, the UN to immediately
implement a cease fire for all military
action in the vicinity of these labs until
they're secured and these pathogens are destroyed.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that with all of these
things, they have kernels of truth. Like, for
example, are their laboratories in Ukraine. Yes,
there are laboratories in Ukraine that research
pathogens and bioweapon defense. They're not
developing bio weapons, but they're researching
pathogens and bio weapons defense there and
and also in many other European countries and
in other parts of the world. So that that's not
untrue. Is it true that the U.S., through the DOD,
is part of a consortium that is supporting
the research being done in a variety of these
labs around the world? Yes, that's true,
but there's nothing pernicious about it.
Would that would the existence of such a lab in
Ukraine in any way justify Russia's invasion? No,
of course not. Are these the US's labs to
order shut down? No, they're not. And so
where this gets into propaganda territory
is that some of the colonels that are there
aren't untrue in a literal sense, but it's
being packaged as a way to provide cover
for talking about things other than the completely
outrageous Russian Russian invasion of Ukraine.
And specifically, this is why this Russian talking
point has been a talking point about Ukrainian bio
labs for so long. Now, Mitt Romney wasn't having
it, Republican Senator Mitt Romney tweeted. Tulsi
Gabbard is parroting false Russian propaganda.
Her treasonous lies will may cost lives. Well,
we've also since learned that Tulsi didn't like
this. And Tulsi started demanding that Mitt Romney
resign. And the idea that anybody would care what
Tulsi Gabbard thinks at this point is genuinely
hilarious. Tulsi doubled down on Twitter.
And she said, maybe Romney needs to resign,
tweeting, quote, Mitt Romney, you have called
me a treasonous liar for stating the fact
that there are 25 U.S. funded bio labs in Ukraine,
which, if breached, would release and spread
deadly pathogens to the U.S. and the world, and
therefore must be secured in order to prevent
new pandemics now. Romney didn't say that she's a
traitor because she said that that's what's going
on, and it's not clear that there are more than
25 in Ukraine. That's actually a question mark,
and they could spread if they were breached, but
we don't know that to be true. But she went on
to say, You claim that securing these labs is
treasonous. No, he didn't say that securing the
labs labs is treasonous. She said the spread of
pathogens is what will cause the loss of life,
not the prevention of such spread. And then,
says Senator Romney, please provide evidence
that what I said is untrue and treasonous. If
you cannot, you should do the honorable thing
apologize and resign from the Senate. Now, of
course, Mitt Romney was saying that. Her parroting
of Russian propaganda is what's treasonous
now, do I think it's literally treason? No,
it's almost certainly not. And Mitt Romney was
using hyperbole. But the idea that Tulsi is going
to call for the resignation of Mitt Romney is just
hilarious. So the important things to keep in mind
about this story, because a week ago, I would
have said, this is not going to go anywhere.
And now this story is everywhere and all the usual
suspects have seized on it. The substance of the
story itself, we went over in detail yesterday
in two segments. I don't want to do it all again
since, you know, how many times am I going to
do that in one week? It's overall a really great
example of Russell's teapot. Russell's teapot
is this idea that Bertrand Russell came up with,
which illustrates the issue of burden of
proof and in particular, burden of proof when
people make an falsifiable claims rather than
shifting the burden of this proof to others.
And the way Bertrand Russell talked about
it was in the context of religion. He wrote,
If someone says, OK, there's a teapot orbiting the
sun or, you know, orbiting somewhere, orbiting the
Sun somewhere between Earth and Mars, and it's
too small to be seen. You wouldn't expect that
anybody would believe that just because they can't
disprove that there's this tiny teapot you get if
he says there's there's this tiny teapot and it's
too small to be seen and too small to be detected.
It's very hard to disprove that, but that doesn't
mean we just assume that it's true that there is
such a teapot. And this entire thing is
based on proof. The U.S. is perniciously
funding biolabs bioweapons labs and there's
something dangerous going on or that, well, we
don't actually have proof of that. We just have.
All we know is there are labs all over the world
and they research pathogens and they research
how to defend against the bioweapons attack. No,
no, no, no. But it's the pernicious nature of
these is being covered up well. So then how
would we know one way or the other? Well, it's
up to you to prove that it's not going on. How
do you prove something's not going on? We just
don't have evidence that it is going on. It's
similar to the Invisible Tiger example I've used
before, which is, Hey, in my studio right here,
there's an invisible tiger, really. But I
can't see it. No, but it's invisible. OK, well,
it's invisible, but it still has weight, right?
So if we put talcum powder down on the floor,
we should be able to see the tiger disturb
the talcum powder as it walks around. No,
because it's a weightless, invisible tiger. Oh,
OK, all right. Well, but I'm sure then that if we
open the door and put a little bit of cellophane
and then take the oxygen out, the tiger will try
to leave the room and we'll see it press up
against the cellophane, right? We'll see this.
No, because it's an invisible, weightless tiger
that has the ability to go through the cellophane.
It's endless, it's a bottomless pit,
and we need to understand that not only
are these claims essentially un falsifiable
to the people making them. These are also much
the same people who were doing the anti-vaxx.
They've just found a shiny new object. Here's
Ben Collins from NBC explaining this.
Speaker 2: Let's talk about it reminds us of
the theories that COVID 19 was deliberately
started in a lab and spread out. Does this
start and live in those kinds of places?
Speaker 4: Yeah, that account on Gab was an
anti-vax account. You know, that's the remaining
legacy of the anti-vax spaces on the internet.
They are conforming to be part of the broader
global far right to push these conspiracy theories
against the Bidens, against Anthony voting against
what they would call the medical establishment
all throughout the world. The global far right has
coalesced around that, and it's worked for Russia,
too. In fact, the test the Russian news agency,
they didn't post anything about biological weapons
attacks that were created in Ukraine in the run
up and one month before the invasion in Ukraine.
But on Thursday and Friday, they
posted 24 separate articles about
what they called biological weapons in Ukraine.
Speaker 1: So this is a long time, long time story
being that that has come out of Russia in the
past and now others are helping to push it. So
that starts with Tulsi Gabbard. Next,
we'll talk about Madison Cawthorn.